my name is Jake and here's some South
Park the fractured but whole gameplay
stick around the CS infiltrate a strip
club called the peppermint hippo if you
enjoy this do us a favor and subscribe
what are you gonna do with that okay
we may be saggy strip club
Wow these ladies are really moving well
don't freak out okay
we're superheroes we can handle this one
of these ladies has information about
the missing hat but though there's only
one thing we can do we have to pick
someone and take him to the VIP room
find someone and maybe there one taste
of that spicy snatches you're a goner
next up in the mood
come back when you're 21 and I'll let
you suck on my ends man
you like bottom shelf booze or cocktail
prices you came to the right ripp look
don't take in the PNA
in here
is behind the bar sweetie
hey YouTube girls ready to party this is
your friend huh [ __ ] hot as [ __ ]
right would you like to take her to VIP
I don't know it's kind of short I like
I'm short you take the one with the
speech impediment come on get some
dances laughs yeah first we get gasses
then we talk oh okay so have you
gentlemen ever had gas to some a girl
with a penis tattoo hey we didn't come
back here to talk baby yeah no talking
until you finished grinding on our jugs
okay you know what this means
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
okay check can chat time oh man
so what kind of work are you guys you
and if you ever dance from the girl here
who has a penis tattoo why are you keep
talking about a stripper with a penis
tattoo yeah yeah classy that's her name
her name is classy
yeah classy with an eye and a little
dick that hangs off the see which [ __ ]
the L out of the a SS of course thanks
eka - we have - okay what are you
talking about this is the worst VIP
experience ever
yeah I did was get farted on you ain't
going nowhere haha hi in the ordinary
skipper I am captain diabetes what nice
night kickin I simply use our powers of
disguise to extract information from you
you won't get away with this
captain diabetes
oh [ __ ] my boner is wearing me down yeah
all I did was get murdered on used to be
put a dollar in strippers as crack as
you owned her for the whole night last
time I pay for a high price $20 stripper
[Music]
hurt surrendered super truckers
[Music]
anyone like a dad
[Music]
[Music]
I want to go to one of those communist
countries that give out government
[Music]
I'm gonna call the Better Business
Bureau and tell them you ski only gave
me half a job
no [ __ ] I think I sprayed my dick
[Music]
burn
[Music]
nuki now let's get back to the main
floor alright guys hope you're having a
good night out there be sure to tip your
waitresses and maybe buy a drink for the
DJ next up on the main stage we've got a
little bit of hot sauce coming up your
way let's give it up for asthma very
dark deck Yusei cause the biscuit game
and then your pictures come out of that
back room nuke
we need to find a way to distract you DJ
I got it
gin and tonics always make my mom pass
out if we can make one if I get
something really strong
he'll be out for sure go make that drink
psychic
[Music]
[Music]
something we can put in a drink
no lineup is complete without a little
taste of paradise we can put in a dress
[Music]
running closer psychic there's certainly
something growth despite that DJ's
Brinkworth around here
[Music]
[Music]
see we've got the makings of a real
knockout straight
this next dancer needs no introduction
she's everybody's favorite treat listen
sorry you got sidekick but nothing in
the world makes me more angry than
fights and awakens that deep-seated rage
that I harbor within me I wish it didn't
have to be sorry but that'll definitely
Oh rad someone finally by the DJ drink
that's really nice of you that went down
really good the DJ sure does appreciate
it Oh oh man I think someone farted in
my drink that's right guys let's get her
on out here that's classy with an eye
and a little kick the [ __ ] the hell out
of ya give it up for Colette hey hey
what you calling me out fo I ain't on
stage yet wait a minute you ain't the DJ
that must be our new kid oh [ __ ]
[Music]